while each mcu hero has coped with the
pain and suffering he or she has faced
in their own unique way
they all came out stronger and better
people because of their experiences
with that in mind these are some of the
most tragic origins of your favorite
marvel superheroes
perhaps one of the most tragic origins
of all the avengers is that of bucky
barnes
a good friend of steve rogers before
rodgers became captain america
barnes was captured by hydra during
world war ii
after falling off a train at a high
altitude leading rogers in the u.s
army to presume him dead however barnes
body was recovered by hydra
who implanted a cybernetic arm to
replace the one that he lost in the fall
and conditioned him into becoming their
premier assassin
the winter soldier barnes carried out
many high-profile hits over the years
including the murder of both of tony
stark's parents
until he was able to break free of his
brainwashing depicted toward the end of
captain america the winter soldier
framed for killing the wakandan king to
chaka barnes was subsequently hunted
down by his son t'challa
also known as the black panther his
eventual escape from hydra
and mission was part of what ultimately
sparked the avengers civil war over the
super human registration act
which ended when barnes and rogers
subdued iron man in a battle after he
learned that the winter soldier killed
both his parents
when you consider that barnes was
presumed dead forced into being an
assassin against his will
framed for crimes he didn't commit and
nearly killed for the ones he committed
against his will
bucky barnes deeply and perpetually
tragic backstory
is enough to make you wonder how he
ended up fighting alongside the avengers
rather than simply staying home in the
fetal position
another avenger with a tragic origin
story is steve rogers captain america
the first avenger rogers desperately
wanted to serve in the u.s military
during world war
ii but was repeatedly rejected during
the recruitment process
due to his small stature and slight
build his gumption was appreciated by dr
abraham erskine who recruited him into
project rebirth
and injected him with the experimental
super soldier serum that turned rogers
into captain america immediately after
the procedure was completed however
erskine was assassinated by a hydra
agent later while attempting to
apprehend armanzola
rodgers lost his best friend and fellow
soldier bucky barnes in a fall
during combat only to be forced into
doing battle with his long-lost
compatriot
years later after bronze was brainwashed
into becoming the winter soldier
of course every hero deals with loss but
cap's victories have often been tainted
by
tragedy after defeating the red skull
for example
he was forced to crash the skull's bomb
latent ship into the arctic ocean
tearing himself away from peggy carter
the woman he loved
you're gonna need a rain check on that
dance
when rogers finally awoke in the modern
era after decades in deep freeze
he was thrust into a new period of time
he knew nothing about
given the loss of his mentor erskine his
friend bucky
and the selfless sacrifice of his love
for peggy captain america's origin story
is one that has been repeatedly marred
by tragedy
the tragic backstory of peter parker is
well known
so well known that the death of his
uncle ben isn't shown in the mcu
when we meet parker he's already living
alone with his aunt may
this also means that parker's parents
are either dead or unable to take care
of him
meaning that he had suffered the loss of
at least three dead and or missing
relatives
before he made his debut in captain
america civil war
that alone would make for an awful
backstory but it only gets worse
in spider-man homecoming parker is
forced to take down the vulture
while parker doesn't kill the vulture
his arrest results in parker's love
interest
liz being forced to move out of new york
city as the vulture is liz's father
later parker has to watch his mentor
tony stark die
after he snaps thanos out of existence
in avengers in-game
this understandably leaves a lasting
emotional trauma
which he is forced to confront in
spider-man far from home
he's one of the funniest avengers but
parker also has one of the saddest
origin stories
among the more tragic backstories in the
mcu is that of peter quill
aka star-lord when quill was a young boy
his mother was diagnosed with terminal
cancer immediately after the death of
his mother
quill was abducted from earth by the
alien known as yondu
which tore him away from the only life
he'd known and thrust him into a life of
crime
quill was forced to become an
intergalactic outlaw by yondu
who threatened to eat him on multiple
occasions if he didn't
god 20 years you've been throwing that
in my face
like it's some great thing not eating me
last and perhaps most heartbreaking
is what quill was forced to do to his
father ego
it turns out that ego caused the cancer
in quill's mother because
to make a long story short his
relationship with her was a distraction
from his quest to take over the universe
quill and eagle ended up doing battle
with each other which resulted in the
death of ego
with the death of his mother his outlaw
youth and the murder of his father
quill's backstory definitely has its
fair share of tragedy
and that's all without even getting into
the death of his father figure yandu
or his star-crossed love affair with
gamora speaking of which
where to begin with gamora when she was
a young girl her planet was invaded by
thanos
and her scrappy but doomed efforts to
save her mother
caused thanos to spare her from being
among the half of her planet that was
about to be executed
upon her adoption gamora was forced to
become an assassin for thanos
and while she did serve him she always
resented him for destroying her previous
life
thanos also had her repeatedly duel her
sister nebula
with the loser slowly becoming more and
more machine
while gamora never lost it definitely
pained her to be a part of
and to witness this abject cruelty
finally
gamora ended up being killed by thanos
in order to complete his acquisition of
the soul soul
while mcu fans saw gamora again in
avengers in-game
it was a version of her from an
alternate timeline before she met the
guardians of the galaxy
this gamora was surrounded by people who
had experiences with her that she'd
never
shared a difficult emotional burden that
could be explored in guardians of the
galaxy vol 3.
with the loss of half her planet her
adoption by thanos
being pitted against her adopted sister
and her death at thanos's hands
gamora's origin story is clearly among
the most tragic of the avengers
although tony stark's hardships were
often mitigated to an extent by his
insane wealth
he still suffered no shortage of tragedy
and heartbreak
when he was a young man tony lost both
of his parents in what was initially
thought to be a car wreck
but would later turn out to be one of
the winter soldiers assassinations
this forced him to take charge of his
father's company at a young age
and although he did very well for
himself achieving world renown as a
manufacturer and seller of cutting-edge
munitions
the loss of his parents still always
shadowed him
years after the deaths of his parents
during an overseas demonstration of his
company's missiles
stark was attacked and struck with bits
of shrapnel from an explosion
some of which nearly struck his heart
forced to rely on a handmade arc reactor
implanted into his chest simply in order
to stay alive
stark built his first iron man armor as
part of a plot to escape from the
terrorist organization that nearly
killed him and although it was
successful
he was unable to rescue the scientists
who saved his life and helped him build
the suit
thank you for saving me
don't waste your life after losing his
parents nearly dying in a terrorist
attack
and failing to rescue his savior stark
was able to use his tragic background in
order to become a better person
and ultimately made the greatest
sacrifice giving up his own life in
order to thwart thanos's plans once and
for all
wanda maximoff's backstory definitely
has its share of tragedy
when she and her brother pietro were
young their parents were killed by bombs
and the siblings only survived due to
another missile failing to explode
that missile had the stark name on it
which caused the siblings to direct
their grief and hatred toward tony stark
and by extension the avengers hydra was
able to exploit this
and convince wanda and pietro to undergo
experiments
that would give them the power they
needed to gain their revenge
eventually the siblings escaped from
hydra and decided to work with
ultron due to his desire to kill tony
stark
the maximoffs eventually joined the
avengers to stop ultron
yet while they succeeded it came at a
great cost as pietro sacrificed himself
to save hawkeye
through the loss of her parents by
stark's missiles her manipulation and
subsequent experimentation by hydra
and the loss of her brother in the
battle of sokovia the scarlet witch's
origin story
is clearly tragic in nature and the
tragedy only continued later
as she lost the love of her life when
thanos killed the android known as
vision
by forcibly removing the mind stone from
his body
nebula's tragic origin initially follows
a path similar to gamora's
she was taken from her world at a young
age by thanos and forced to become an
assassin
from here however the adopted sisters
paths diverge
they were routinely forced to fight each
other with gamora routinely the victor
and nebula slowly carved up by thanos
and made more machine than living as
punishment
leaving her understandably bitter toward
gamora and her so-called father
i will hunt my father like a dog and i
will tear him apart slowly
peace by peace knowing thanos viewed
gamora as a potential successor to his
throne
nebula was driven to prove she wasn't
the inferior daughter
which further drove a wedge between the
sisters in fact when mcu
fans meet nebula she's hell-bent on
killing gamora a dynamic that proves
stubbornly resistant to change
although nebula slowly comes around to
viewing the avengers as her allies
and standing up to thanos in his mad
quest to wipe out half of all life in
the galaxy
a formidable warrior through the course
of terrible circumstances
nebula finally learned to recognize love
and friendship
but she could have and should have had a
far easier life
dr strange's origin story is steeped in
misfortune
a successful neurosurgeon steven
strange's bad luck begins when he gets
into a car accident that renders him
unable to use his hands
following this he sells off nearly all
of his possessions to fund efforts to
heal his wounds
an obsession that ends up pushing away
his love interest christine palmer
while strange is eventually able to
salvage his bond with her
he's unable to pursue a deeper
relationship with christine
or anybody else really after his efforts
to regain the use of his hands
lead him to become a sorcerer supreme
and eventually the protector of the
mystical sanctum based in new york city
it's a long story strange's journey from
shallow surgeon to magical protector
is not without its setbacks aside from
the emotional difficulty involved
he's almost immediately pitted against
cassilius
then forced to confront dormammu the
ruler of the dark dimension
with the fate of the universe hanging in
the balance no big deal right
although strange hasn't faced the level
of tragedy that some of his fellow
avengers have had to cope with
he did lose his career and had to
basically rebuild himself as a person
making sacrifices along the way bruce
banner has his fair share of tragic
chapters in his backstory
as marvel fans know he was a gamma
radiation expert who was contracted by
the us military to develop a version of
the super soldier serum that turned
steve rogers into captain america
but an accident left banner changed and
always at risk of turning into a green
rage monster whenever he got angry
that's my secret captain
i'm always angry
banner attempted to isolate himself from
those he loved as he feared what would
happen if he lost control
and he was also being hunted by the
military banner was forced to try and
find a cure for his condition
so he wouldn't be treated as a weapon
and could live a somewhat normal life
but he was forced to become the hulk
when the abomination the gamma-infused
alter-ego of special ops vet emil
blonsky
attacked harlem banner ultimately fled
the united states entirely
only returning from exile at the urging
of nick fury's avengers initiative
transformed by the forces he attempted
to control hunted by the government he
worked for and prevented from living a
normal life
banner is an avenger whose backstory has
definitely been darkened by tragedy
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you